I have to ask you a few questions about Solskjær.
Because I am, after all, Norwegian.
I understand.
As you might have understood.
So Ole Gunnar Solskjær has become ...
... and interim manager for your team.
Exactly.
He has done quite well.
He has won most of the matches.
He has come in with a very nice energy and ...
... he has really made the team believe in the football that he wants to play and ...
... also that we should believe in ourselves and in our qualities.
I think he has done a really good job since he came in.
Is that something that you've missed in this team?
That feeling?
Eeeeeehhh.
Careful, now!
I'm not sure what to answer to that.
I only want to praise Ole, I think that he's done a very good job since he came in and ...
I know that a lot of people like him and think that he's handled ...
... all the players well since he came there.
That's what I can say.
Yeah, yeah, but ...
If you ...
Let's just say ...
If you owned the team, if it was your team ...
Would you hire him then?
I guess you have to say that!
I've been sitting here praising him, and I think he's done a fantastic job.
But it's not up to me to sit here and answer that.
I don't think so.
But as I said, he's done a very good job.
He's hired!
You're hired!
How wonderful!
Yes.
Fun to be here!
You've driven down from Manchester.
Yes.
I forced him. He doesn't like interviews and stuff like that.
But I told him: «Skavlan! You don't say no to that!»
It's actually true.
It's thanks to me we're sitting here!
And you can tell that to the rest of your team, as well!
I'll do my best. I can't make any promises, but I'll do my best!
Firstly, Börje and I have been talking ...
... not about football, but about proposals.
How spontaneous was it when you, I don't know which one of you did it, proposed?
I was the one who proposed.
Was it well planned, or was it ...
It was quite planned.
I thought about ... Or, I spent six or seven months planning it.
Maybe.
That's quite long!
That was a very long time, actually!
But it takes a while finding the ring and things like that, and you want it to be good!
So ...
Yes. I found a nice ring.
And then we traveled to the Maldives, Maja and I, and then ...
I had fixed ...
Did you feel that «it's happening now»?
No.
I've always wanted to get married.
And he has been like: «I don't want to get married».
So I had actually accepted that.
And thought that we wouldn't get married.
I was playing a game there! I tricked her a little.
So I had no idea. And he did it the third day of our journey.
You would think that he would do it the first day. Or the last. The last is maybe a bit strange, but the first!
But it was the third!
I had planned it perfectly, quite simply!
How had you set this up?
We were going to have a little picnic under the stars after dinner.
Yeah.
It was hard to fail with that. But ...
In the middle of dinner, we had maybe been there in ...
30-40 minutes.
Yes, it wasn't long.
... the skies opened up and it just poured rain.
And we were sitting underneath a tent made with sticks, not a real tent ...
So it just poured everywhere.
And had he had time to ask the question, or ..?
No.
So I became very stressed there!
And I tried to play calm and ...
«It doesn't matter, it's just a little rain, we can go back later.» But I think Maja noticed ...
... that I was quite stressed!
Really stressed!
And I just said: «It's just a little rain»!
But we then went to a restaurant that was nearby.
And we had a nice dinner.
And then we went down to the beach and ...
And I popped the question!
Down on your knee?
I went down on my knee. But I had ...
The ring is in a box.
And I thought that I should bring the box, because I wanted to open it when I was down on my knee.
But I didn't know where to put this box.
Because you can't have it in your pocket ...
I was wearing shorts. It was in the Maldives.
So ...
So I thought, «where should I put this box»?
So right before we left, I stuffed it into my pants.
And I put it right here.
So I had to walk like this!
She didn't see anything, at least!
So it worked out.
So I just went behind a bush and pretended that I wanted to pee and then I took the box out.
They call you «The Ice Man».
Exactly.
It doesn't feel like that. You're not very ...
I actually don't know why I've gotten that nickname!
Do you understand that, do you wake up with «The Ice Man» every morning?
I think they're referring to how he seems on the outside.
With the media and ... They rarely get anything out of you!
I suppose it must come from that.
I think.
I think it's a mix of how I seem from the outside ...
I'm quite a private person.
I'm not very fond of sharing too much.
And I also think it's because I'm quite calm on the field.
So I think it's a mix of those two things.
That you keep your cool?
Yes, exactly.
Do you two have the same temper, or do you have different ones?
We're both heated.
Yes! You now think that he doesn't have a temper, but he does!
Yes, I think that «The Ice Man» sounds very calm!
No, no, no!
I can get very mad.
There's a Börje Salming in there?
Yes.
I don't think I ... Well, I'm not so sure of that!
He's at another level, I think!
But I'm very calm now, so it's all good!
Of course I can get mad, but I think that both Maja and I have a pretty heated temper sometimes.
How much do you follow ...
Your job is very modern, it's called an influencer.
But you also do a podcast, and you have a blog, and you do different things in social media.
You have moved to Manchester.
And the two of you work with very different things.
Yes.
Do you keep up with each other's work?
No.
I support you, and you support me, but we're not ...
... very ... I don't really want to have Victor in what I do.
And he obviously doesn't want me in what he does.
I go and watch matches and things like that, but ...
He doesn't come home and talks football with me.
For example, if she does a podcast, does she expect you to listen to all the episodes?
Oh yes.
I've heard that many times!
I can admit that I haven't been very good at that.
No! Really bad!
Yes. But he always reads everything I write.
Things like that.
I do.
Does it limit you that he plays in Manchester United?
Yes. But it also benefits me, of course, I'm not stupid.
I take advantage of that.
But I think we've found a good balance.
Before it was harder for me to know what I could and couldn't write.
I could come home and just be like «ughhh», because there was something written in the news, and ...
... and he would come home from training and I would just feel like ...
... «I'm just gonna lock myself in here, because he's gonna wanna have a chat with me».
But I've learnt now, for sure.
There's a term called «footballer's wife».
I know that you don't like that term.
No.
I think that it's degrading to women, quite simply.
I am married to Victor and he plays football, and I understand that ...
... it's easy to use that word.
But I still feel that there's something degrading in that word.
And that's why it provokes me, I think.
I also think that people don't really ...
People look down on it and think that the women just stay at home and do this and that.
While he plays football.
And they don't know anything.
Do you feel that you're ...
... being looked at when you're on the stands watching a game?
That people view you in a certain way and that they label you?
That they place you somewhere?
I used to think so before. But now I feel like I'm starting to become my own person.
Today, when I wrote that I was going here, lots of people said that they would watch because I'm here, and not because he's here.
I feel that I've arrived somewhere.
I have to ask you a few questions about Solskjær.
Because I am, after all, Norwegian.
I understand.
As you might have understood.
So Ole Gunnar Solskjær has become ...
... an interim manager for your team.
Exactly.
He has done quite well.
He has won most of the matches.
He has come in with a very nice energy and ...
... he has really made the team believe in the football that he wants to play and ...
... also that we should believe in ourselves and in our qualities.
I think he has done a really good job since he came in.
Is that something that you've missed in the team?
That feeling?
Eeeeeehhh.
Careful, now!
I don't know what to answer to that.
I only want to praise Ole, I think that he's done a very good job since he came in and ...
I know that a lot of people like him and they way he's handled ...
... the players since he came there.
That's what I can say.
Yeah, yeah, but ...
Let's just say, if you owned the team, if it was your team ...
Would you hire him?
I guess you have to say that!
I've been sitting here praising him, and I think he's done a fantastic job.
But I don't think it's up to me to answer that.
I don't think so.
But as I said, I think he's done a really good job.
He's hired!
You're hired!
I have to ask you how ...
... a day in your life looks. Because you're living the dream, according to many.
To be a professional football player, and be able to ...
... buy a really expensive house, live in England and play for Manchester United.
A lot of people have that dream.
And to live the life that you do as well.
But there is an everyday life for you as well.
How «normal» is that?
We have an everyday life, but none of us have that «it's Monday, it's seven in the morning» ...
... «get up». We don't have that.
And we understand that that is a luxury.
Yeah. We don't have that Sunday anxiety.
We really don't.
And we appreciate that.
So you don't get up at seven, when do you wake up, then?
When I wake up every morning?
When do I get up? Nine?
Quarter to nine? I get up at ...
You get up a nine?!
I get up at nine.
I live quite close to the training facility, so that's pretty sweet.
I don't do a lot of things before I go, I brush my teeth and then I leave.
And how much do you train?
That depends.
How tight the matches are.
But we try to train every day.
But sometimes ... Lately, we've gotten a day off after every match.
And I think that's important, to rest the body but also ...
... the brain, the mental aspect is also very important. To get away from the football and to get rested.
How important was that for you, Börje, to rest?
Yeah ...
We didn't rest actually, we trained every day.
But that would also depend, like you say, if we were away on a game and played very well and came home very late ...
... we would get the next day off.
But if it hadn't gone well ...
... and if we had lost, for example ...
... we would train the morning after.
But that would depend on what coach we had, a few of our coaches were completely mad in my opinion.
The first two coaches we had were really good, but then we had a few who were completely ...
I don't know what to say about them, to be honest.
They were people who didn't ...
They weren't like Solskjær?
They were no good. They were no good.
They just yelled. They just yelled at the young boys.
We who were older didn't care, but the younger ones ...
... they could hardly play. And they barely dared to make a pass at training. And I think that's wrong.
What do you do when  you relax?
Yeah, what do I do, Maja?
What does he do then, Maja?
He plays PlayStation.
Or he just lays in our sofa. He just lays there.
And he watches YouTube.
But then he will watch PlayStation games on YouTube.
So it's either or.
She is exaggerating!
No, I'm not!
So he comes home, sits down in the living room and plays?
Yeah.
He has his own room now.
We had to get him his own room because he was yelling so loud you could hear it all over the house.
And I needed to work.
He has a gaming room?!
Yes.
Because I needed to work!
I'm actually very happy with that room, it's become very nice!
So ...
I've been happy about that. I need it! I disturb Maja when I play! Or, she says that I do.
So it's good that I have my own room where I can sit and yell by myself.
You're having a child.
Yes.
And it's not that far ahead.
No.
Seven weeks now!
And then ...
... the question is, what will happen to this gaming room of his?
He has asked about that, what it will be like ...
... as if I have the answer to that, i don't know!
I have spoken with Maja and asked her if ...
... if I can spend extra time playing now!
Before the baby arrives!
The last weeks!
Make sure I really play!
Yes, and there is also this thing with ...
... sleeping until nine in the morning.
I make sure I sleep now, because I know that there might not be so much sleep.
Yes, I think that you should sleep a lot now!
I have to make sure I sleep now. And I'm very sleepy in the morning.
So that will be a challenge. But I'm looking forward to it.
It's very unreal to me.
But we were at the hospital, and ...
I got to see the ultrasound.
And then it became very real.
It was very moving.
Were you there during the delivery?
No.
I wasn't there for the first one.
No, it was in Canada.
The doctor was old fashioned, so they didn't allow me to be there.
But I was there for the second one.
Because he was late, and he didn't get there in time.
Because she was six weeks early.
And I got there straight from training and just stood there and didn't understand anything.
I just hurried there fast.
And I was standing outside, and the nurse came out and said: «What are you standing here for?».
«Well, I don't know», I said.
«You should be in there!» she said, and pulled me inside, put clothes on me and I got to be there.
I was so fucking happy!
It was fantastic!
A lot of people say that.
You didn't faint?
No. But ...
I had a lot of ...
I couldn't complain, but ...
She almost tore my arm apart!
But I just had to put on a brave face.
You can't complain when you're there.
You just have to be supportive.
I can imagine that there's a lot of things that I have to look forward to.
Oh God, yes!
You do.
I can vouch for that!
Good luck, and thank you so much for being here tonight, we're gonna get some more guests in here!